este es un ejercicio de khan academy
sobre máximos y mínimos locales también
conocidos como relativos nos piden que
marquemos los puntos máximos locales en
la gráfica como siempre pausa en el
vídeo y vean si pueden encontrar cuáles
son los puntos máximos locales vamos a
ver como un repaso recordemos que un
punto máximo local o relativo es un
punto en la gráfica en el que los
valores a su alrededor son menores o
iguales al valor de la gráfica en ese
punto
por ejemplo este punto no es un punto
máximo local porque a su derecha la
función es más grande que en este punto
tiene un valor mayor en este punto
este punto parece la cima de una montaña
y esa es una buena forma de verlo para
identificar un punto máximo local así
que este es un buen candidato si nos
movemos un poco a la derecha podemos ver
que hay valores menores a la función y
si nos movemos un poco a la izquierda
también hay valores menores a la función
x
este es un punto máximo local hagamos
otro ejemplo aquí nos dicen que
marquemos todos los puntos mínimos
locales en la gráfica bueno un punto
mínimo local o relativo es un punto en
la gráfica en el que si analizamos todos
los valores de la gráfica que hay a su
alrededor encontramos que son mayores o
iguales podemos verlo como el valle de
la gráfica aquí podemos ver un gran
valle y este es el fondo por lo tanto
este es un punto mínimo local o relativo
y podemos ver que si tenemos x valores a
su alrededor los valores de la función
en esos x valores serán iguales o
mayores al valor de la función en este
punto y como pueden ver eso no es
verdadero para ninguno de los otros
puntos que encontramos en esta gráfica
hemos terminado nos vemos en otro vídeo